[Music]
on the coast of Northern Ireland a vast
plateau of basalt slabs and columns
called the Giant's Causeway stretches
into the ocean the scientific
explanation for this is that it's the
result of molten lava contracting and
fracturing as it cooled in the wake of a
volcanic eruption but an ancient Irish
myth has a different accounting
according to legend the giant finn
mccool lived happily on the north end
room coast with his wife Oona
they're only disturbance came from the
taunts and threats of the giant Ben and
Donner or the red man who lived across
the sea in Scotland the two roared
insults and hurled rocks at each other
in dramatic shows of strength once then
tore off a great clump of land and
heaved it at his rival but it fell short
of reaching land instead the clump
became the Isle of Man and the crater
left from the disturbed earth filled
with water to become locked nay the
Giants tough talk continued until one
day Ben and Donner challenged in to a
fight face to face and so the Irish
giant tossed enough boulders into the
sea to create a bridge of stepping
stones to the Scottish coast then
marched across in a fit of rage when
Scotland loomed before him he made out
the figure of Ben and Donner from afar
Finn was a substantial size but at the
sight of his colossal enemy thundering
towards him his courage faltered with
one look at Ben and Donner's thick neck
and crushing fists then turned and ran
back home with Bennett Donner fast
approaching Finn trembled as he
described his enemy's bulk to Oona they
knew that if he faced Ben and Donner
head-on he'd be crushed and so una
hatched a cunning plan they needed to
create an illusion of size to suggest
Finn was a mountain of a man
whilst keeping him out of sight as Ben
and Donner neared the end of the bridge
una stuffed her husband
in a huge cradle disguised as an
enormous baby finlay quiet as Ben and
Donner pounded on the door the house
shook as he stepped inside una told the
enraged visitor that her husband wasn't
home but welcomed him to sit and eat
while he waited when ven and Donner tore
into the cakes placed before him he
cried out in pain for he'd shattered his
teeth on the metal una had concealed
inside she told him that this was Finn's
favorite bread sowing a seed of doubt in
Ben and Donner's mind that he was any
match for his rival when Finn let out a
squawk Ben and honors attention was
drawn to the gigantic baby in the corner
so hefty was the infant swaddled under
piles of blankets Ben and Donner
shuddered at the thought of what the
father would look like he decided he'd
rather not find out as he fled Ben and
Donner tore up the rocks connecting the
shores breaking up the causeway what
remains are two identical rock
formations one on the north Antrim coast
of Ireland and one at Fingal's cave in
Scotland right across the sea ready for
more myths choose your next adventure
you can tag along with Thor as he faces
his own band of giants or watch what
unfolds when Arachne accidentally
insults the goddess Athena
[Music]